M Mes invités : Hélène Buzzett,
MiMichel C. Auger
etet Stéhanie Grammond.
BoBonsoioir à vous trois.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Ça a commencé à Ottawa
vevendredi midi, la santé publie
dudu Canada a dit qu'elle n'aimt
papas beaucoup les rassemblemens
dede 20 personnes. On demande ax
prprovinces d'être prudente.
AuAujourd'hui, on dit qu'Omicron
prprogresse en Ontario et va
dedevenir le variant dominant ds
ququelques jours. Soyez prudent,
etet la troisième dose est une
bobonne idée. Qu'est-ce que vous
dédécodez dans ses messages qu'n
enenvoie?
- - Ce n'est pas la première fos
àà Ottawa, qu'il n'y a pas de
cocontrôle sur aucun système de
sasanté, qu'on envoie des messas
paparfois beaucoup plus prudent,
plplus stricte par rapport à la
sasanté publique qu'on reçoit au
niniveau des provinces, qui ontà
gégérer les attentes de la
popopulation. En soi, ce n'est s
unune première fois. Mais on set
efeffectivement qu'il y a un
cecertaine malaise face à Québe.
EtEt on n'en a discuté dans le
papassé, le fameux 20 de Monsier
LeLegault, de Monsieur Arruda
ététaient-ils des départs Monsir
LeLegault? On sent qu'il y a un
mamalaise, mais ce n'est pas la
jujuridiction d'Ottawa de dire x
prprovinces quoi faire.
MaMais toute la question de la
trtroisième dose, sa relance
l'l'enjeu de l'équité mondiale.e
gagain marginal que l'on fera ac
unune troisième dose au Canada,
ququ'est-ce qu'on voulait obtenr
sisi on administrait ses vaccins
enen première dose ailleurs dans
lele monde pour éviter la
prpropagation de nouveau varian?
IlIl y a une question beaucoup
plplus grande dictée mondiale.
- - Qui est une très bonne
ququestion. Comme dit Hélène,
onon a vu cet équilibre joué,
cecette danse depuis le début,
OtOttawa se montre parfois plus
prprudent que certaines provincs
ququi administrent dans la vraie
vivie les chose. Est-ce que vous
vovoyez le même processus?
- - Je vois aussi que le variant
OmOmicron semble plus dangereux
ququand le disais au début, plus
cocontagieux. On voit ce qui se
papasse au Royaume-Uni. On a
lilittéralement confiné.
PePeut-être qu'on a décidé un pu
trtrop vite au Québec de la lime
dede 20 personnes.
CÇa nous a surpris, ce n'était
papas à la conférence de pressùu
c'c'était prévu, ça devrait être
ququelque jour plus tard. On
auaurait peut-être changé d'idée
sisi on avait attendu quelques
jojours. Et je n'exclus pas qu'n
rerevienne sur cette décision
paparce que ça semble assez
sésérieux. La santé publique
d'd'Ottawa a beau ne pas gérer e
sysystèmes de santé, c'est quand
mmême des experts de santé
pupublique reconnue.
JeJe serais très intéressé à
sasavoir aujourd'hui ce que pene
lala santé publique du Québec.
- - J'espère qu'on ne va pas
rerejouer dans le même film qu'à
NoNoël l'an dernier, où on s'est
reretrouvé en janvier avec un
cocouvre-feu, avec des gars qui
auaugmentaient beaucoup.
AÀ la décharge du gouvernement u
QuQuébec, ce n'était pas éviden.
OnOnt navigué avec beaucoup
d'd'inconnues pour prendre une
dédécision pour le temps des
ffêtes. Par contre, il y a une
chchose qu'on savait absolument
sasans aucune ambiguïté, c'est e
NoNoël et le 25 décembre.
PoPourtant, ça fait longtemps
ququ'on le sait, mais il n'y a
totoujours pas de test rapide àa
didisposition de tous les
QuQuébécois comme on aurait aimé
leles avoirs. Évidemment, la
trtroisième dose, on peut en
didiscuter, mais il est trop tad
popour Noël. Par contre, les tes
rarapides pourraient vraiment êe
ututiles et permettre aux gens e
sese tester pour éviter de
cocontaminer la famille et les
amamis avant une réunion.
- - Cette semaine, Monsieur Para
didit la semaine dernière qu'il
avavait de bonnes nouvelles pour
cecette semaine pour toute la
popopulation. À suivre, il y a e
coconférence de presse demain à3
heheures. Armée, tour de table -
dedessus. Excuse de la ministre
AnAnand. Elle ne perd pas beaucp
dede temps.
- - On l'avait vu, si elle la
grgrande architecte de la
lilivraison des vaccins contre a
COCOVID. Ça a fonctionné. Enseme
coconstater que Madame Anand vet
memettre cette efficacité au
seservice de la question des
mimilitaires qui ont fait l'objt
dede comportement inadéquat
sesexuel. Les excuses aujourd'hi
ététaient, il faut le dire,
mamanquait un peu de patient.
OnOn a parlé pendant 40 minutes.
CÇa manquait d'âme un petit peu
papar rapport à d'autre excuse
ququ'on a vue dans le passé.
LaLa grande question et si Madae
AnAnand va réussir à faire la
prpromesse, à savoir de transfér
totoutes les accusations qui sot
fafaites des tribunaux militairs
vevers les tribunaux civils. Ele
didisait aujourd'hui que c'est
ququelque chose qu'elle espère
fafaire très rapidement, elle a
paparlé en début d'année. Ça fat
ququand même un mois. C'est ça e
vrvrai test de Madame Anand.
- - Pardon.
- - C'est de ma faute.
- - Je pense que c'est une bonne
nonouvelle de voir Madame Anand
ququi prend les choses en main s
sasa nomination. Elle a été très
rarapide, tant mieux, parce quea
fafait depuis 2015 conseils qu'l
fafaut prendre des mesures, deps
lele temps où la juge Deschamps
avavait remis son rapport et les
rerecommandations tardaient à êe
imimplantées. Dans l'armée, on a
unun gros problème de recruteme.
EtEt on peut comprendre que ce
n'n'est pas tentant pour une fee
enen ce moment de dire qu'elle a
fafaire carrière dans l'armée. n
vovoit la pénurie de main-d'oeue
ququi est réelle. Ils ont besoin
d'd'engager presque 7000
pepersonnes. Ils auront de la
didifficulté à respecter le budt
d'd'avoir le corps de leur
efeffectif qui sont des femmes
d'd'ici cinq ans. Il faut donner
unun coup de barre si on veut ue
ararmée qui se tient.
- - J'aurais voulu voir M. Trudu
s's'excuser aussi. Je comprends
ququ'on va dire qu'il s'excuse e
trtrop d'affaires.
- - Il ne l'a pas fait ce matinn
coconférence de presse?
- - C'est quand même lui qui a
dodormi avec le rapport Deschams
dadans son bureau pendant des
anannées sans rien faire.
J'J'aurais rendu ça plus
sosolennelle et plus officielle
avavec le premier ministre à cet
enendroit plutôt que le ministre
dede la défense seulement.
- - Loi 21, avec le cas de
ChChelsea, c'est enseignant engé
papar la commission scolaire
mamalgré la loi 21 avec un voil.
EtEt elle a été mutée à d'autres
fofonctions. Ça appert coller
dedepuis jeudi dans l'opinion
pupublique, il y a eu des
rereportages. Au Canada anglais,
çaça a beaucoup collé jeudi,
vevendredi et samedi.
IcIci aussi. Je vous fais entene
MoMonsieur Trudeau et Monsieur
LeLegault.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU,
prpremier ministre du Canada
- - Je suis en désaccord profond
avavec le projet de loi 21.
JeJe ne trouve pas que
dadans une société libre
etet ouverte, quelqu'un
dedevrait perdre sa job
àà cause de sa religion.
EtEt de ne pas donner l'excuse
auau gouvernement du Québec que
c'c'est de l'ingérence fédérale,
mamais de simplement dire non,
leles Québécois sont en désaccod
avavec ce principe.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - Quand on regarde le projet
dede loi 21, il a été appuyé
papar deux partis, la CAQ
etet le Parti québécois,
ququi représentent plus que
lala moitié des Québécois.
LeLes sondages montrent qu'il ya
unune majorité de Québécois qui
sosont d'accord. C'est une loi
ququi est raisonnable.
J J'étais content quand même
dede voir, dans la réaction
dede Justin Trudeau au début,
ququi disait : "Bien là,
c'c'est aux Québécois à débattre
dede cette loi-là entre eux."
- - Évidemment, ce n'est pas une
susurprise que M. Trudeau reste
cocontre cette loi. En même tem,
ilil a été extrêmement prudent.t
n'n'a pas envie de rouvrir tout
çaça. La loi est contestée et ia
jujusqu'en cour suprême.
- - La loi est contestée et il a
lele verrou de la clausese
dédérogatoire utilisée deux foià
l'l'endroit de la charte
ququébécoise et de la charte
féfédérale. On sait bien il y a
pepeu de chances que ça se rende
trtrès loin, même si le
gogouvernement fédéral intervie.
CeCe que je note, c'est que ça
fafait deux ans que cette loi a
étété adoptée et on est au premr
cacas. Ça m'a fait beaucoup penr
auau rapport Bouchard Taylor, il
n'n'y avait pas véritablement de
crcrise quand on regarde ça de
prprès. Un cas en deux ans, on a
mimis beaucoup d'énergie politie
llà-dessus pour un cas en deux
anans.
- - Stéphanie?
- - Je pense que ça a été payant
popour Monsieur Legault et poura
CACAQ parce qu'il a réussi à
jujumeler la loi 21...
SaSammer M. Trudeau dans une
sisituation difficile. Quiconque
ququi veut cataloguer la loi 21
esest considérée comme étant
cocontre la laïcité, ce qui n'et
papas le cas. Si on s'en était
tetenu à appliquer l'interdictin
dedes signes religieux vraimentt
auaux gens qui sont des
rereprésentants de la force
cocoercitive, donc les policier,
leles juges, on aurait pas eu ts
ceces ennuis et on n'aurait pasu
àà se battre comme ça en cours
prprobablement. Mais on n'en est
llà et ce n'est pas terminé,
paparce que la clause dérogatoi,
onon va en parler encore
lolongtemps.
- - J'avoue que je ne suis pas
d'd'accord avec mes deux collègs
susur la question du nombre.
CeCette personne qui a été passe
paparce qu'elle embauchée par la
susuite, il faut savoir aussi qe
cecette loi 21 à probablement
emempêcher l'embauche de beaucop
d'd'autres personnes. Alors le
nonombre et probablement beaucop
plplus grand que un.
CeCette dame représente peut-ête
totous les autres qui n'ont pas
étété embauchés et qu'on voit
momoins, mais ça existe aussi.
- - Mais on ne le sait pas.
- - On ne le saura jamais. Touta
ilillustre de vision radicalemet
didifférente sur cette notion de
lalaïcité. J'allais dire le Cana
ananglais, mais ce n'est pas
seseulement au Canada anglais, a
rereligion n'est pas considérée
cocomme une idée, elle est
coconsidérée comme une identité.
EtEt dès lors qu'on tombe dans
cecette adéquation, on ne peut s
cocomprendre que quelqu'un se
fafasse passer pour son identit.
AlAlors qu'aujourd'hui, Monsieur
LeLegault a parlé d'un chandail
susur lesquels serait écrit Je
vovote Parti libéral, personne e
reremet en question que les idés
pepeuvent parfois être obligée
d'd'être mises en sourdine. Au
gogouvernement fédéral, on a
paparfois eu de cas des
séséparatistes qui a été
cocongédiés.
- - Ça fêtent parti de leur
ididentité, qui d'autres peut de
quque ce n'est pas vrai?
- - C'est un débat. Mais d'un
ccôté, on dit que c'est une idée
esest une idée peut être mise de
ccôté huit heures par jour, alos
quque les autres disent que c'et
leleur identité 24 heures sur 2.
- - Ça ne vous a pas frappé, pae
quque Monsieur Trudeau a été
clclair, il est contre. Ça ne vs
a a pas frappé le signal qu'il a
enenvoyé à Québec, qu'il n'a pas
enenvie d'une joute politique.
- - La clause s'en va devant les
trtribunaux. Il peut s'il le vet
apappuyer une des contestations
jujuridiques. Mais ça ne veut ps
didire que les juges vont suivre
leleur avis. Et lui arrive bien
plplus souvent qu'autrement de
didire que les provinces ont
raraison contre le gouvernement
féfédéral. À la fin, c'est une i
prprovinciale et ce n'est pas de
soson ressort de.
- - On ne sait pas pourquoi la
cocommission scolaire à engager
cecette enseignante. Et conseile
lala commission scolaire savait
ququ'elle portait le voile?
- - J'ai parlé au président de a
cocommission scolaire, qui me
didisait qu'on était tellement
dadans une pénurie de main-d'oee
quque des fois les entrevues
d'd'embauche se faisaient au
tétéléphone. Même si on n'a pasu
lala personne, on connaît la loi
etet on est supposé réitérer la
loloi lorsque la personne se
prprésente. C'est un argument un
pepeu léger.
- - Les deux cas se regardent et
sisi les mêmes arguments qu'on
enentend d'un côté comme de
l'l'autre : protection des drois
inindividuels. Légendées ce qu'l
y y a la charte, qu'on ne devrat
papas enlever quelque chose qu'n
coconsidère être dans notre
ididentité.
- - Il y a rien de neuf apports
ququ'on a la possibilité de mete
unun visage sur la loi 21.
JuJusqu'ici, ça demeurait peut-
êêtre un débat théorique.
EtEt ça prend une nouvelle
didimension. Mais effectivement,
lele reste des choses suive leur
cocours. Il y a eu une première
dédécision rendue au Québec para
cocour supérieure et le juge a t
quque c'était une utilisation
dédésinvolte et inconsidérée dea
clclause dérogatoire. Il a dit
quque ça violait effectivement a
chcharte canadienne et la charte
ququébécoise. Il a dit aussi que
çaça violait les lois
ininternationales, dans la
dédéclaration des droits de
l'l'homme. À mots couverts,
c'c'était une invitation à faire
apappel à la justice
ininternationale. Tout ça est dt
etet n'est pas fini, on continua
d'd'en entendre parler.
- - Le gouvernement a fait appel
dede cette décision. Ce n'est ps
nonotre dernier panel là-dessus.
2020 secondes chacun, en s'atted
àà quoi demain?
- - Il y a ce fameux 40 milliars
dede dollars pour les enfants
auautochtones. C'est quand même
trtrès intéressant. C'est une
cocompensation gargantuesque, la
momoitié de cette somme irait pr
dédédommager pour le passé.
J'J'espère qu'il y aura un débat
llà-dessus parce que quand on
vovoit les orphelins de Duplesss
nonous rappeler qu'ils n'ont eu
quque 25 000 $, peut-être qu'ily
a a lieu de s'interroger sur les
momontants accordés dans ce cas.
- - J'ai hâte de voir ce que le
gogouvernement va faire sur
l'l'inflation, est-ce qu'on va n
paparler vraiment dans cette mie
àà jour? C'est ce qui fait peur
auaux citoyens.
- - L'inflation même chose, cete
popour cent aux États-Unis la
semaine dernière. Espérant que
lele gouvernement va trouver une
fafaçon de s'attaquer à sa. Ce
n'n'est pas nécessairement à lui
d'd'intervenir plutôt qu'à la
babanque du Canada, mais ne pas
ajajouter de l'huile sur le fe